Ben Saul is UN special rapporter on
human rights and counterterrorism and
joins me from the heg Mr Saul good to
have you with us on Al jazer I'm
referring also to a press release that
was uh released by your good s and with
your name on it of Israel and Lebanon un
experts deplore extr territorial use of
lethal drones to conduct killings in
counterterrorism using that document
could I start by asking that your
experts say and I quote uh that Israel
has neither provided any legal
justification for the strike nor
reported it to the security Council as
required by article 51 of the United
Nations chter we're talking about the
attack uh on individuals in Lebanon who
censures Israel for this
now so we're talking here about the
strike on a senior Hamas leader last
week and of course hamas's original
attack on Israel on October 7 came from
the territory of Gaza it did not come
from Lebanon uh and by escalating uh the
conflict to the territory of Lebanon by
striking Hamas leaders there Israel is
clearly in violation of international
law it's a breach of lebanon's
sovereignty it's a violation of the
prohibition on the use of force under uh
the United Nations Charter uh and Israel
hasn't presented any evidence that Hamas
was attacking Israel from Lebanon itself
so this is of concern it should be of
concern to the United Nations security
Council and all states should counsel
Israel not to continue to escalate this
conflict one of the problems that uh
we've seen is the um many narratives
that are coming out of Israel when it
comes to their um attack on individuals
and groups they see as a threat it is a
dangerous precedent isn't it to say that
we can attack you wherever you are in
the world without giving any proof and
without any mandate via the UN or any
other official body it's a dangerous
Pandora's Box to
open absolutely it violates the
sovereignty of any country where Israel
uses Force against suspected terrorists
it's not a new phenomenon I mean of
course Israel has been assassinating its
perceived enemies for many many decades
I mean if you go back to the Munich
Olympics attack in
1972 in sub successive years Israel
hunted down and murdered uh those
responsible it thought for those attacks
in the process of course killing some
innocent people uh current Israeli
leaders including the Prime Minister and
the defense minister have threatened
that they will hunt down and murder
Hamas operatives wherever they are uh
across the world uh this is incredibly
dangerous it's a breach of international
law it's a breach of Human Rights it's a
violation of the the rights of other
countries and it doesn't solve uh the
security threat to Israel by not
respecting international law as you say
and not being pushed to do so by the US
who could ask Israel to stop all of this
both the US and Israel May well sort of
Ru the day when they start lecturing
other nations to to mind their own
business as such and and is there is
there a real concern here uh that
countries such as Russia uh and China
Myanmar North Korea can quite easily
turn around to the United States and say
we'll do what we want and we'll go after
who we want it's none of your
business well sadly some other countries
have been engaging in precisely this
practice uh I mean the US was of course
involved in the war on terror in many
violations of international law Russia
has been murdering dissidents in
countries like the United Kingdom Saudi
Arabia of course murdered infamously uh
a journalist in the consulate uh in
Turkey some years ago so unfortunately
there are some uh seriously lawbreaking
countries and this kind of practice if
it meets with impunity if powerful
states like the United States or
International organizations like the
security Council do nothing about it
then it encourages these practices to
continue uh the United States of course
has said it has been encouraging Israel
to respect international law but at the
same time it's been unconditionally
giving weapons to Israel to continue its
campaign of war crimes in Gaza so the
United States has not been sufficiently
serious and hasn't pulled all of the
levers it has uh to encourage Israel to
respect international law Ben it's good
to get your Insight into this I'm sure
we'll be uh unpicking it as the days uh
progress for the moment thanks very much
for joining us from the
ha